the Polish opposition is calling this
one of the biggest anti-government
demonstrations in decades up to half a
million people on the streets of Warsaw
saying no to the government of prime
minister mattesh maravietsky who's
dismissed the protest as a circus they
also denounced president Andrei Duda
blaming his pis or Law And Justice party
for the rising cost of living
many carried EU Flags
I'm fed up with the rulers I want to
live in a European country that's free
and Democratic where minority rights in
women's rights are respected where the
church does not rule I'm Marching for my
daughter and my granddaughter and all my
relatives
Sunday marks the anniversary of the
first partly free elections in Poland in
1989 among the Marchers Le fonsa who led
the solidarity Union in a successful
fight against communism here and was
then elected president
[Applause]
and former prime minister Donald Tusk
who heads the Centrist opposition party
Civic platform
we are here today so that all of Poland
all of Europe all of the world can see
how strong we are how many of us are
ready just like 30 40 years ago to fight
again for democracy for a free Poland
for our rights nothing can stop this
voice this wave the giant has awakened
the war in neighboring Ukraine has
increased the popularity of the law and
Justice party which has spoken out
against the Kremlin but some protesters
accused the government of copying the
authoritarian politics of the Communist
era
I've already lived through an era when
talented people were not allowed to take
their exams if they were not in or did
not know somebody in the Polish
Communist party I don't want my
grandchildren to live in the same age
that's why I'm here
most polling suggests the governing
party will likely win the Parliamentary
elections later this year but fall short
of a majority that could open the way
for opposition parties to take power if
they maintain their current support
levels and manage to agree among
themselves Nadeem Barber Al Jazeera